what we're going to be talking about
today is a presentation based on a Blog
that I wrote I guess earlier this year
around whether or not kubernetes is kind
of the next fault domain and the
argument that I'm making is largely that
kubernetes has become the the common
operating system for for the cloud for
hybrid Cloud deployments multi-cloud
deployments multi-region deployments
anything where you need to be able to
run
a lot of the copies of the same
application across multiple sites it may
be route users to them the is is a is
largely getting run on kubernetes these
days
um
and in my opinion kubernetes meets all
of the criteria for an operating system
right it manages work and runtime
right manages the resources without
explicit user interaction like when's
the last time you picked which CPU corer
on your MacBook was was running your
application you don't do that because
the operating system handles that for
you it's got a common input and output
layer so as a as an application
developer or as an administrator as a
user I interact with the common API
Gateway and the system handles all of
this for me and it abstracts away the
complexity of running an application
across a cluster of machines right so
the the thing that kubernetes that's
special about kubernetes is really that
that operating system isn't limited to a
single machine not only does that open
up some challenges to running an app
across nodes in kubernetes but it opens
up this concept of having to build apps
that not run not just across servers but
across kubernetes clusters effectively
your kubernetes cluster becomes your
fault domain
for building your application for
building highly resilient applications
now the reality is there's a lot of
multi-cluster challenges in kubernetes
some of them have been solved today some
of them haven't right
um there's challenges around networking
there's challenges around load balancing
and service Discovery identity and Trust
so like with networking we're talking
things like there's there's cnis there's
ebpf they're vpns there's these things
called Vans or virtual application
networks for load balancing you've got
Concepts like API gateways and service
meshes
for security they're
um you you have to
have a consistent view of what a user is
allowed to do in multiple different
locations that's a really challenging
problem identity and trust
this is really how do I validate that
the the user is who they say they are
right to try to avoid situations where
um
a user that's working in one kubernetes
cluster isn't also
um someone isn't trying to pretend
they're them in another cluster and do
bad things
um there's of course infrastructure and
Performance challenges
uh there's this whole concept of how do
you manage failure recovery
uh observability monitoring and then of
course you know state which is some one
of the problems that Cocker hdb can help
with
Raphael you've built a lot of these
applications over the years where do you
see some of the biggest challenges in
building kind of multi-cluster
applications on top of kubernetes
yeah one place where I had significant
challenges is the fact that
kubernetes operators are cluster bound
so they can control they can automate
and control everything inside the
cluster but when you go multi-cluster
and multi-region
it's not that obvious how you can
declare your intention as a user
with something that impacts multiple
classes you have to come up with some
some solutions that is not unfortunately
that is not just limited to writing an
operator that doesn't work
um
other things that that
um
I had to deal with is trust and identity
is an important one that you have here
uh because in kubernetes there are
kubernetes is also it's not just a
failure domain in my opinions all the
trust domain it's very easy to validate
that apologies apart and you know
further destroy and connect to another
part is actually what it's saying it is
it's easy to generate certificate within
a cluster but when you have to connect
with between multiple clusters uh how do
you how do you create that trust is is a
problem that you have to solve
um
and then another one is unavoidable but
still something to consider that is is
latency right that's not really just a
problem of kubernetes it's a problem of
it's just the way it works when you do
deployment across multiple regions but
latency will impact
um several decisions so you have to take
that into account
yeah I I mean we spend a lot of time
talking about latency and cockroachdb
right
um we've got a bunch of optimizations to
make the read path super fast
but um we do if we're in a multi-site
configuration
we we largely are always going to be
impacted on the right side uh when we're
writing to multiple regions we've got to
wait until a quorum of them are are
updated I'll I'll re I'll uh double down
on your operator comments we have an
operator for cockroachdb but it is it
only works for a single site deployments
right for customers who want to use
cockroachdb across multiple physical
kubernetes clusters we recommend other
install patterns that uh that allow the
administrator to to be more explicit
making decisions the last thing we want
to do is have
like a API controller effectively that
is making decisions based on incomplete
information about the cluster right what
we've talked about what we could maybe
do to solve that problem in the future
um I know that the kubernetes ecosystem
and there's like Cube Federated and Cube
and multi-cluster there are a couple of
cigs that they're trying to find
different ways to tackle this problem
um I know this is something that the
community's been talking about for a
long time we have the advantage of
theoretically we could bootstrap this
with our own database if we wanted to
but we haven't we haven't gone down that
path yet
um I know we're going to talk a little
bit about kind of the failure recovery
mechanisms here a little bit later but
I'd love to dig in a little bit on the
networking right so because there are a
lot of different options here there's
kind of the CN cni layer stuff ebpf
right
um uh there's there's also VPN based
Solutions like Submariner that we've
talked about in the past and and then
Vans like Scupper what what do you think
is going to be the long-term solution
for multi-cluster networking in in
kubernetes
so so the premise here is that obviously
when you deploy these Solutions across
multiple clusters they need to
communicate right and I call that kind
of a communication East West
communication as opposed to North South
where where you know that which is the
traffic that comes into the cluster and
it's your workload here we're talking
about
the world is having to communicate with
each other so for East West
um across clusters and across possibly
you know data centers and re-cloud
regions there are some solutions I think
that uh that you have mentioned
I think I
um I think that ebpf has a good chance
of of becoming the the preferable one
um
I think that psyllium already has a
solution in this space
um but in general I see that that's that
could be a good technology to build this
East-West tunnel tunnels between
uh between clusters
there is enough of Destruction there
where you know you could make it at the
same time very efficient and and
Abstract a lot of the underlying
complexity
that you may find when you do this setup
so
as an extension of that right
there are definitely circumstances where
pods in one kubernetes cluster need to
be able to discover pods in another
kubernetes uh cluster either for high
availability purposes or potentially
just for synchronization purposes
so what do you kind of see as the state
of the art for like multi-cluster load
balancing service Discovery are you like
a service mesh fan are you an API
Gateway fan do you prefer like the CDN
style approach where
um where you have kind of like a global
load balancer like what's your what's
your philosophy there
My Hope Is that there is a specification
for multi-clusters most multicluster
Services I think it's called MCS within
the kubernetes one of the kubernetes Sig
that's that's a specification that works
well for
tunnels between SD and tunnels between
clusters where you don't need to involve
ego resend Ingress to do that
My Hope Is that we can
um we can you know standardize around
that kind of approach possibly that kind
of specification
um
the other yeah
um the multi-cluster service mesh is
another option here but
um there's no need to have the overhead
of the side car you know for for just
for Discovery and and load balancing
yeah
um I will mention
um because I forgot to at the beginning
of the of the call we are um we are
accepting questions in the Q a and uh we
will be raffling off some t-shirts too I
think it's the
five best questions to get asked so if
anyone has questions it please drop them
in the webinar chat I'd be happy to
we'll we'd be happy to try to field them
live or any that aren't completely on
topic for what we're we're talking about
at the moment but are related we'd be
happy to get to at the end of uh end of
the the webinar
before before we move on Raphael are
there other multi-cluster challenges
that we're not talking about here
something I missed Maybe
I think it's a complete list a list for
as far as I can tell the the monitoring
and observability is is a big one right
it's
um
yeah collecting collecting
um those matters across multiple
clusters it it's not only
there's you know you you need to have
something else where that uses a
collector and then you have to solve the
scalability problem and it's often you
know as as you are more and more
successful it can become an issue and it
can become a bottleneck I think I think
we're seeing a lot of evolution in that
space and the open Telemetry
standardization it's a very good thing
you know this is a thing that we had to
build into cockroachdb was
um kind of monitoring capabilities for
cluster-wide monitoring capabilities so
that we could
see what any given node's opinion was of
the health of the rest of the cluster to
help us diagnose these types of issues
but that's a single
like that's a specific implementation do
you see
do you see any common patterns emerging
around how how we're going to do this
and uh kind of a multi-kubernetes
cluster World across arbitrary
applications
foreign
is to
you know produce the metrics and the
traces and collect them towards a common
collector maybe applying sampling if if
need be
but I see
and and so solution like tanox tunnels
and um
I don't remember the other cortex right
those two are good a good approaches
um
but I see what in the actual
implementation phase I see a lot of
struggle within my customers in in
achieving the correct level of
scalability
scale I should say the correct level of
scale yeah
I mean distributed State Management
generals challenging right we've solved
it for
for kind of relational transactional
workloads but I'm an arbitrary basis
there are a lot of different solutions
that are out there and they all have
their their strengths and weaknesses
maybe we'll talk a little bit about that
later here in the in the chat but I
imagine that observability and
monitoring has both that challenge plus
kind of the single pane of glass
challenge Right Where I Need to I care
about these the health of my application
um not necessarily the health of the
given kubernetes right pod or even a
cluster in a multi-cluster world
um and I certainly care about when users
have a degraded experience because
they're being routed
to a more remote look remote location
than than they necessarily need to be
um
so there we do have a a question in the
in the the Q a uh what's the solution to
have Geo redundance redundant kubernetes
clusters that are hosted on-prem right
um I I will say that in general the the
customers that
that I've worked with that had kind of
either an on-prem or hybrid Cloud
deployment
um most of them ended up using openshift
right
um
the
I think the important thing with on-prem
clusters is at least from a copper hdb
perspective is making sure that you have
similar performance characteristics out
of all of your different sites and you
have reliable connectivity between those
sites those seem to be the most
important things for cockroachdb Raphael
you've built more hybrid application
Stacks than I have is there any
um is there anything else that you'd
have to add on top of that
yeah I um
I think
um I don't see a lot of this difference
between the cloud and on-prem
um in terms of building you know
geographical distributed uh Solutions
but I would say just the way the the
question is phrased
um
we look for solution to our applications
you know availability not necessarily to
the cluster availability I would say
it's more important to think about the
application than the cluster let's treat
the Clusters as disposable
um so at that point it doesn't really
matter where they run it only matters
that you can once Sun the disaster
happen or some problem you have some
problem you can bring them back right
and you can reapply quickly the
configuration possibly with guitars and
then we can focus on making the
applications available you know and
resilient to a disaster
um so refreshing the question what is
solution to making application available
[Music]
um and especially stateful application
when you want to deploy this application
across multiple cluster possibly hybrid
or you know multiple on-prem geography I
think we're going to go down a little
bit deeper into that question in the
rest of the presentation so so um we got
we got one more question that I'm in a
field while we're we're on this topic
which is around upgrading uh
cross-cluster applications to a newer
version so with cockroachdb we um we
support this out of the box and in a
multi-cluster deployment we generally
recommend you upgrade one region at a
time
now cockroachdb can roll pods and
continue to have the service live even
in the region that's being upgraded and
the database is designed to be able to
support running in kind of a mixed
version mode during an upgrade so we can
do that without an outage
my experience largely is if you solve
that from a data layer perspective the
the application Services end up being
pretty easy to upgrade
um the uh the challenge is usually at
the data layer when you have to like
make schema changes or some other sort
of data migration
um and cockroachdb was the design of the
box to solve that problem uh Raphael
have you experienced any other kinds of
challenges with that type of uh pattern
no I I agree with you it's interesting
I'm in the middle of those kind of
discussion with a customer but yes
I I will yeah take care of doing the
schema changes and the database upgrades
first and then the status piece of the
application it's way easier to deal with
so I'm going to kind of summarize my my
take on nests right
in kubernetes in general but
particularly in multi-cluster kubernetes
it's important to design your
application stack to survive when
failures happen rather than to have kind
of a disaster recovery strategy which
was the traditional way of handling
applications
um and and that largely means we need to
rethink how we build systems we need to
plan
for the system continue to operate when
something's broken rather than
planning to try to recover from uh
outage
when something's broken and and largely
the reason for this is in a sufficiently
distributed system something's always
broken
um you know you're running hundreds of
thousands of pods for microservices
you're running say
150 nodes of cockroachdb across three
sites maybe the likelihood that you
don't have some problem somewhere in
your environment at any given time is
pretty close to zero so it becomes
imperative to
design the system to kind of be able to
handle
the the types of events that used to be
considered a disaster now Raphael I know
you're an expert in the in how how to
build systems to survive disasters and
kubernetes so uh do you want to kind of
lead this part of the conversation sure
thank you Keith
um so this table is uh from a
um white paper that we wrote for the
cncf tag storage that talks about
this idea of cloud native Disaster
Recovery I'm going to try to talk about
it in in con comparing and contrasting
it with traditional disaster recovery
so
in traditional Disaster Recovery the
detection
of the disaster is usually a human
decision right so something starts to go
wrong
there is a meeting
the decision is made that we cannot
recover with the usual you know aha type
of approaches somebody press a big red
presses a big red button and we are now
in Dr mode right then then there are
then a lot of stuff users needs to
happen some of it is automated some not
but it's usually a manual decision in
Cloud native this has to recovery we
want to or disaster management we want
to
um we want that decision to be made by
the system so the system autonomously
realizes that a piece of it is not
responding anymore and takes action and
then the recovery procedure itself like
I said usually
what we see you know large organization
is
um a mix of automated and and manual
actions and that's the reason why you
know there is this B annual uh biannual
um you know Disaster Recovery exercise
in in some places and sometimes it's
well done sometimes not so well done but
um
is there is manual action there is there
are actions that are not commonly
executed the people you know are not
used to they may fail why are they doing
why they do it and do them
in Cloud native Disaster Recovery
everything needs to be fully automated
so the machine makes the decision to
that something needs to be done because
there is a failure and the actions that
we take are fully automated
then fto and lpo are the two main
Disaster Recovery metrics right one is
RTO is the time that it takes to recover
the service RPO is the elapse of data
that we lose because of the disaster
so in in traditional disaster recovery
depending how how you architect the
system you could be between minutes and
hours of downtime right
in Cloud native Disaster Recovery we
we want to be near zero uh downtime
essentially the time that it takes for a
nail check to take place and detect that
there is something going wrong and start
redirecting the traffic to the healthy
locations
and for a recovery Point objective RPO
in traditional Disaster Recovery you can
have from from zero to hours depending
on the storage solution that you use
right if it's backups it's probably ours
if it if it's more of a synchronous file
or volume synchronization it's probably
it could be around zero but for cloud
native Disaster Recovery is disaster
management it it can be zero especially
if we are talking about strongly
consistent Solutions which you know
cockroaches one of them
and then now
um thinking about the ownership of these
processes right the disaster recovery
processes so a little bit out of the
technology more about the organizational
aspects
normally
um in in large in large organization
um the the ownership of the business
continuity of an application is always
in the application team but normally
what happens is that the application
team turns to the storage team or the
infrastructure team and says
what guarantees can we can you give me
for this database or for this uh volume
right and and then they take whatever
the answer is whatever is available in
in the organization sometimes there are
tiers but essentially that the very
limited choice
my argument is that in Clarity Disaster
Recovery because the the responsibility
of owning the disaster recovery process
is going to be in the in the team
and and because they will have to choose
the correct middleware and they will be
the owner of the middleware so so it
could be a conquer CB or it could be
etcd or it could be Kafka but they are
gonna own it or maybe they're gonna
purchase it as a service but still
essentially they are the owner
um and then the other thing that I
noticed doing this kind of deployments
and this kind of exercise is that in
traditional Disaster Recovery the actual
technical capabilities that essentially
enable the ability to recover so the
disaster recovery procedure our backup
um log shipping or you know volume
synchronization
something that happens at the storage
layer
uh instead in in Cloud native disaster
recovery
we need more capability from the
networking layer in particular we need
that installs communication that we were
mentioning before and we need a good
load balancer Global load balancer that
can detect
um issues and and can make a decision
about how to steer the traffic yeah so
so we have a question in the chat about
whether or not backup is still an option
for for very large
um
environments uh specifically I think the
questions around data at least with
cockroachdb the answer is yes
um we we do distributed backup to each
location
so so that you we can solve for that
problem I think in general
the the the question really then becomes
how fast can you get those backups off
site right
um
so so with cockroachdb the data is
replicated to multiple regions so even
if you lose a single region you still
have a full copy of the data backed up
in another region but for regulatory
reasons sometimes you do need to have a
like a tertiary storage location for for
that type of stuff so is it an option
yes but it does if you end up having to
go to that
it looks a lot more like a traditional
Dr type of a solution where it takes
hours to get the data back loaded
potentially which is why largely we
architect these solutions to survive
what traditionally would be a disaster
and treat it as an ha event because the
because
true disasters end up being incredibly
expensive from like a human
um perspective if it's a if it's a
financial application or whatnot it can
have a monetary impact on the company
there's usually a lot of Fallout to to
having a true disaster happen so
anything we can do to avoid
um a disaster and treat be able to treat
as an ha event is is usually best the
one thing that Raphael you didn't
mention that I'm gonna I'm going to
mention is that 70 of disasters are
either caused or exacerbated by the
human interaction
one person doing one thing in in the
wrong order
um Can can turn uh set like a failover
from say a couple of minute type of
event to a couple of hour or a couple of
day type of event
um someone fat fingers a command someone
deletes the wrong file somebody does
something that they probably didn't even
mean to do it's not like there was
necessarily even intent but but uh
people are the most fragile element in
um in disaster recovery so the more you
can remove the people
the less likely you are to have a
disaster so
um thank you for for running with that
um Raphael Gemini other context you'd
like to add on backup I think it's an
interesting question it comes up often
I would say we if you if you can deploy
a clone native industry solution you
know whether with caucus or other
um other of these new generation of
State distributed workloads
you you probably still want to do
backups but not to protect yourself
against a disaster it's more to protect
yourself against logical errors right
say say make a wrong deployment and you
drop a tip you know your code drops a
table that was not supposed to be
dropped now you still have a backup
right so you have backups for those
reason not for protecting you for
against disaster recovery against
disaster
there's always the chance that there
will be a real disaster and you will
need those backups so it's good to have
them
um you just actually answered one of the
the other q a questions about
um
um how do you account for replicating
corruption so in cockroachdb
um
the the replication happens at the raft
log layer and the actual file system
work happens through a KV store so
um
so you would someone would have to have
submitted bad data for us to have
um have like file system corruption
propagate towards multiple nodes in
cockroachdb if the if the node notices
file system corruption it will remove
itself from the cluster
um and since all of the data is
replicated at least three times that
will still leave us with a quorum of
replicas to process against and then
after a handful of minutes the cluster
will take the two remaining good copies
and and create a new third clone from
um and if you're really really concerned
about that you can up replicate to five
or seven uh X replication to for your
most important data
um
there was a kind of a follow-up question
around uh does Storage level replication
uh make sense to the cloud native World
um or would you only rely on on database
level replication for me personally I'd
like uh storage replication for some use
cases in a single cluster perspective
but multi-cluster there tends to not be
enough data guarantees uh to be assured
of that consistency so you're I
generally like either using some sort of
a message bus like a Kafka
to transport data between regions or a
database like a durable state store like
a database to transport data
across a across kubernetes clusters
rather than block or file system level
replication which
doesn't necessarily guarantee that um
but you'll have a replica that's
consistent as of a point of time but
you're not guaranteed of what exactly
that time is and you won't be able to
verify there's no like
transaction semantic to verify that the
data has been updated right and so
that's the more distributed you get the
more likelihood that those types of um
issues will pop up and so I generally
recommend either a message bus based
solution or a like a database based
solution Rafael do you have any other
thoughts on that no I agree I don't see
file level replication or
um Block Level application as a
something in Cloud native perhaps object
storage replication right that that's uh
you know if you have enough storage and
behind the scenes it's replicating it's
doing things that yeah I guess
that's a good point right for
replicating backups off-site so that you
might use a solution like that to do to
a tertiary location
right
um but that's not going to be live block
storage that's going to be file level
replication not Block Level replication
anyway right
um
so isn't this as expensive
right so
in a traditional Dr type of environment
you have one site that's your primary
hot environment it's processing all of
your traffic and you have the second one
that's either warm or cold and by warm I
mean maybe you're doing some
non-business critical work in the
secondary site like running bi
dashboards or something like that or
it's truly cold where it's just there to
receive
data and context from from the the hot
site right and both sites have to be
able to handle a hundred percent of your
production workload so that means that
you have to be provisioned at 2x minimum
of everything plus whatever added
infrastructure you need to keep those
those two sites in sync
um and as Raphael mentioned the the
failover and failback is expensive and
risky even when the failover works
really well the failback
actually is a lot of times even more
risky than the failover because
everybody only tests in One Direction I
don't know if you've ever had this
experience Raphael where the failover
works great and then they realize that
they don't have any run books on how to
fail back
you've been have you lived that world
before I I uh yes I think I can attest
to that yes yeah so um when you started
to talk about Cloud native Disaster
Recovery
um all of your sites are supporting
users are hot effectively
um and that and that means when you lose
a site your remaining sites are
are there to support uh you distribute
whatever work was on that site that
failed to the remaining sites which
reduces your total overhead of operating
the solution
so effectively in Cloud native Disaster
Recovery you're going to recommend three
or more sites right that allows you to
do consensus-based replication it allows
you to
um not have an external Observer
deciding when a disaster has happened
right
um at least with cockroachdb when you
lose if a site gets say has a network
partition the that the database knows to
shut itself down if it can't see a
quorum of the nodes in the cluster so
that you know that uh business
operations aren't continuing to be
processed in that site which is really
important
um but the real key thing is the more
distributed you are and by more
distributed I mean across the more sites
that you're distributed the less
overhead you have to survive any
particular event right so if you're
across three sites
you need to have a 160 percent of your
total infrastructure provisioned to be
able to continue to to run your
production operations during a site
failure there are four sites it's 35 to
45 percent five sites 25 to 35 percent
Etc et cetera at five sites you could
also potentially if you wanted to design
your system to survive to
site failures concurrently
you could provision your infrastructure
to do that as well now that would change
your overhead numbers here but now all
of a sudden
we're in the rarified era of having to
worry about multiple region Cloud
regions going down simultaneously
and because there's no failover or
failback all you're doing is routing
users to a different site when those
sites come back online they just rejoin
the cluster get caught back up and then
start processing user transactions right
cockroachdb makes this really really
easy we actually spent an enormous
amount of time building the SQL engine
to enable us to do that
and the the great thing about using
Congress Indiana the covers for a
problem to solve these types of problems
is it gives the apps that are running on
top of it those same superpowers right
um so assuming that you're using either
the database for all of your state or
the database plus say a distributed
message broker like a Kafka that also
can survive these types of
um events
all of a sudden now you're in a
situation where our
um a site failure say AWS US-1 goes down
or Azure West two goes down or Google's
Central one goes down
um you still in uh full operating mode
maybe your performance isn't as good as
it was when you had all of your sites up
and running but you're able to continue
to process all of your important
business logic
um there is one question in the chat
that I want to talk to here around
what's my opinion for about data
consistency in a multi-cluster
environment personally I think it's
super important I wouldn't be a
cockroach to be if I didn't it is kind
of the problem we were designed to solve
um the one thing that I'll point out is
that kind of traditional consistency
requirements in either a single server
or a single site
are um kind of are have a limited window
of vulnerability just based on the
physics right a single server when
you're in a like you're running a lower
level of consistency let's say you're
running like snapshot or repeatable read
in your database or maybe running a
non-posix compliant file system
right your vulnerability window to
um to like data entropy problems is is
really small right on a single server
you're talking
microseconds
and a multi-server but single like
physical site situation you're probably
talking still less than a millisecond of
actual vulnerability window as soon as
you're multi-site your best case
vulnerability window is is one round
trip between your site and its next near
site right there's a couple of orders of
magnitude more vulnerable
there are certain use cases that can
tolerate that type of vulnerability and
if you can there are some great like
nosql type solutions that they can help
you do state synchronization right
um in those types of scenarios but if
you're dealing with anything that's like
Financial transactions Inventory
management anything that require a
transaction like accounting stuff
anything requires any kind of auditable
results
um I think it's exceptionally important
to to think about this before even you
get started if you can right now granted
cockroachdb Bing uh postgres wild
protocol protocol compatible means that
we can kind of come in after you've
already built some of your app and help
you get moved but it's it's a little
harder right so
um
let's go ahead and and talk a little bit
about what this looks like with
cockroachdb right so
we do a lot of multi-cluster kubernetes
um whether it is multi-region across a
single cloud multi-cloud provider like
I'm showing in this diagram a hybrid
like a lot of the work that I've done
with Raphael in the past where you have
some physical on-prem sites and you've
added some Cloud sites in
all of them basically have the same
fundamental challenge right how do you
manage an app that runs across
um multiple kubernetes clusters so on a
single basis cockroach Steve is actually
really good at doing this on its own
um now for our
um
dedicated and serverless offerings our
databases service offerings where we're
running fleets of systems they're
running across multiple uh kubernetes
clusters we have built our own kind of
control plane I think we're using an EPB
ebpf based networking solution under the
covers and
um we've certainly kind of built our own
identity and access management
um plug-ins for both the on the
administrator side and on the app side
so that users can you know use the same
credentials to log into the database
regardless of which node or which site
they've logged into
um you know we've had to try to solve a
lot of the the distributed backup
problems that we were talking about here
all right
um
the thing that I like the most about
cockroachdb in general is
um
but Davis doesn't care
um so the database
works by when it when a node joins the
cluster it it announces its location
in physical location in the hierarchy
and that allows the database to kind of
self-manage replicas to make sure that
we're
um replicating the data as appropriately
for both the performance requirements
the application and the resiliency
requirements that the administrator has
put in place by default we're going to
deploy data in the most resilient
pattern possible and it also gives you a
lot of flexibility on the network and as
well as having workloads be hot in in
all of these sites right
um Raphael and I didn't have time to get
the the kind of the demo set up
um for today but um we have on uh on a
pretty regular basis have have done
demonstrations of of just this thing
where um where we'll set up red hat on
all three of the cloud providers
um or openshift and all three of the
cloud providers and then run a single
cockroachdb cluster across it right
um there's we have a lot of options as
far as as that goes and one of the
things I like the most about openshift
is because it is not not so tightly tied
to a single cloud provider you can have
a common kubernetes operating experience
by using openshift as your kubernetes
distro in all these locations
so what does the future look like
um I have started to already see the
kubernetes ecosystem converge around
some of these Solutions like I think
ebpf Raphael I agree is probably where
we're going to land for for a lot of the
Cross cluster Network routing the
East-West Network routing types of
problems that we've been talking about
um there's some great kind of
multi-cluster controllers and like
cross-plane and good multi-cluster that
are very promising you know identity
management with thought said and spice
uh spice DB key cloak
like there are a lot of of great pieces
of future Tech that
some of which are usable in production
today like evpf some of which are still
kind of in in development but
um what's your thought on what kind of
what's the next what's the next thing up
that needs to be solved in the community
I think uh
um
Global load balancing is is the next is
is a thing where
maybe the Gateway API can help
but
um I haven't really
I I still have to see a
a solution that is not very Cloud
provided specific
to declaratively say
I want this traffic to be a load
balanced to these three regions these
three cluster clusters and this the pods
deployed in these clusters okay
um
yeah I I there is as far as I know and I
could I could have missed some some
steps but as far as I know there is no
specification there uh the the Gateway
API could probably support that semantic
but I haven't seen any unreal
implementation for doing it yeah so
that's important because
the global balancer like is like we said
is not just a traffic load balancer at
this point to we certainly need that but
it needs to be more it needs to be
something that realizes that something
is going wrong and uh steers the traffic
so in this I call it a smart Global
balancer in the sense that also as the
concept of health checks and possibly
also as the concept of advanced uh
traffic load balancing policies like
when you're doing these things you know
really geographically distributed you
probably want the clients that are
closers to a location to be always
redirected there right can you configure
that policy or is it just random
um
we obviously need those those
capabilities I haven't seen something in
in the kubernetes
area that really addresses there are
some attempts but there is nothing uh in
my opinion that is material that really
addresses that problem and I think we
need to work on that yeah
so um there were a couple of questions
in the chat around how the data
replication Works in cockroachdb so I'm
going to take that real quick
um we um yes the replication happens in
real time so cockroachdb is split up in
these things called ranges Each of which
is its own raft group
and those are synchronously replicated
and so what what happens is in say a 3X
replication uh configuration for a
transaction to be uh committed
um a full Quorum of those replicas have
to be updated before the transaction is
committed
um and then any remaining replicas are
updated within what we call our closed
timestamp window which is
I think by default I think we have to
250 milliseconds
um so the data replication happens in
real time and then what we do on the
read end is we distribute the authority
to act to the raft leaders
um so the raft leader for any particular
segment of a table or database can
respond to read requests without having
to do a quorum check so that's how we
kind of avoid some of the like the the
worst the worst side effects of the uh
of the Cross region latency
um
so we had a couple other questions we
are
um uh we are about out of time so I'm
going to go ahead and run through the
last slide or two and then anyone that
wants to stick around and uh get a
couple more questions thank you I'm
happy to do that so
um if you'd like to to learn a little
bit more about
um how to run cockroach to be on
kubernetes there are a lot of different
options uh you can go and and check out
our website
um I've got a bunch of blog posts on
this topic Raphael's got some bunch of
blog posts on this topic some of them
are ones we co-authored together
um and there's a lot of other great
content on the Cockroach Labs website
around all of this
oh press the wrong button and um for
those of you don't want to stick around
for the Q a